this podcast is brought to you by raycon
my friends if you don't have any raycon
earbuds what are you doing what are you
listening to what are you listening this
podcast on it better be raycon earbuds I
love them they're super light super
compact the battery charge lasts a very
long time they have customizable sound
profiles earbud tap functions noise
isolation awareness mode and a whole
bunch more and the greatest part about
that is that they're half the price of
other premium audio Brands ready to buy
something small with a big impact go to
buy raycon.com playing today to get 15
off your raycon order that's by
raycon.com brain to score 15 off by
raycon.com brain so I believe uh I
stayed up in that hospital all night
long
in pain to a degree
um but psychologically broken uh blaming
myself believing that I should have been
that person I should be the one that
can't breathe or I I should it should
have been me there not the other way
around and um I remember that night
experiencing in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
are in the OG studio today we have a
very uh special guest there's a homie
I've known for quite a while now met him
through our buddy Bart Quan he was
training BART to be a boxer let's go we
got coach PJ in the house you may have
seen him from fight camp videos he is
probably your online coach that gets you
through the day gets your Fitness going
gets that heart rate up and set your
boot right for the rest of the week
coach PJ in the house everybody wow what
an intro David my gosh bro you do that
for everybody everybody man it's so
special and loved right now wow this is
great the the good thing of what I
really like about my podcast is that you
know some people will ask me can you get
this person on and I go listen I don't
know him oh I don't give a [__] about it
that's true
but you know me you know me so so I feel
like there's so many interesting stories
out that you know and when people reach
a certain level like notoriety you could
hear their story elsewhere right of
course and I think people generally like
my interview style because it's very
casual but at the same time like you
guys have to understand like we're gonna
have like an hour to an hour and a half
conversation I actually have to care
about the subject matter at hand
it helps to know the why behind the what
and to have some involvement from the
heart you know yeah and I gotta sit here
and listen to this [__] so you know if
I'm if I'm here just to interview
somebody just for other people's
entertainment's sake which is fine
because this is a you know a platform
for entertainment but I still got to
keep it to my roots where I do things
because I enjoy it
so I love that I love that what a lot of
people may not know about you which is
what I'm curious about which I don't
even know this backstory at all is that
you are actually so once again just to
refresh
boxing this is this is this man's world
but before boxing was football it was
and you know we were talking about this
before uh we started this podcast where
I was talking to you about me watching
this Oscar De La Hoya interview and
hearing him talk about the transition
that he has to go to in his life
outside of boxing right
and hearing him talk about it he sounds
like he has no purpose and a reason to
live yeah and that [__] always [__] me
up a little bit because I think I've
I've been in that place before where
I've I've had to make shifts not because
I wanted to but because I had to yeah
and sometimes when people
identify their whole being with their
career and their job they think that
this is the end-all be-all for their
whole life I had a conversation with uh
my wife about this where
you know for her she's always
challenging herself 24 7. and that's
what I really love and appreciate about
her and so sometimes when she's you know
in this mode in this early on her career
she kept on nitpicking at these these uh
these job and these career opportunities
that she has as she was trying to find
fulfillment through her job and
basically what I was explaining to is
because I heard this from somebody else
and it really affected me was
a straight sentence your career is not
your life your career will have to end
one day because so let's say you retire
right what do you do then do you just
contemplate life and you have nothing to
look forward to
you know not everybody gets to pick and
choose what they want sometimes you have
to deal with the cards that you're dealt
with and then you create opportunities
through that and so when I saw this with
like that Oscar De La Hoya interview and
I've seen the other Fighters like Mike
Tyson and everybody else where they had
to do this like career change but your
story is a little different you were a
football player right right and you went
from football and having to switch into
boxing
um I want to know how that happened
let's start from like where you grew up
your whole story oh man so where Did We
Begin Where Do We Begin we'll start off
with uh where I begin my origin story
starts in the City of Brotherly Love
Philadelphia you see I'm repping I was
actually born and raised in Lansdowne
Pennsylvania a little small suburb
outside of Philly but you know we were
at Philadelphia all day every day 24 7
365 baby but it is it is the the place
where all of my family still lives today
um I've been very fortunate and blessed
to now live here on the best coast in
sunny Southern California
um but my my Origins are are back in the
east coast
um beautiful mother and father uh
unfortunately didn't have the best start
at a home where my mother and father
divorced really early on
um and you know my mom did an amazing
job of raising me and my younger sister
by herself
um but all of that kind of changed and
you know January 27 1997 my father was
murdered
um it was at a bar in Philadelphia
um believe it or not how old were you I
was eight years old I was eight at the
time or seven going on eight and it was
probably the first point in in my life
where my life was changed forever where
I didn't realize it at the time that my
dad was gone and I was never going to
have a relationship with him I was never
going to get to go to his house anymore
I was never going to get to learn how to
be a man from him and and I didn't
understand it fully and and that
definitely had a lot of of pain and a
lot of deep wounds that I'm still
unpacking even to this day
um but I definitely am grateful now for
the life that I have had since it
because my mother did again an
incredible job she took the mantle and
decided that I'm going to raise these
kids right she did everything that in
her path through sacrifice uh to learn
to grow she ended up you know taking on
multiple jobs she ended up graduating
from college ended up going to uh an Ivy
League school went to University of Penn
got another degree I started a business
all while raising two kids by yourself
she was a boss and I I give my mother
all the credit where credit's due
because she's a great woman and did an
incredible job raising two incredible
people I'll talk about my sister at some
point because she's a boss in her own
rights but
um Mom holding it down for us uh all of
those years and while she was doing that
you know she got me involved in some
sports you know didn't have a lot of uh
father figures around and a lot of great
men in my life so she put me on the
sports so I played soccer I got involved
with some football early on and so I got
to get really close to coaches and they
really helped and mentored me a lot um
so I picked up football probably you
know like 10 or 11 but it wasn't like I
was playing you know every single week I
wasn't in all these kinds of leagues it
wasn't until like High School freshman
year of high school that I started to
like
start to really like football and I was
like oh this is this is this is fun you
know I'm tall I'm fast I can play both
sides of the ball let me let me let me
invest a little bit into this so
um freshman year I went to Monsignor
Bonner High School right outside of
Philadelphia and uh it was a interesting
experience going to an all boys Catholic
school but your boy learned how to play
football and I started to really excel
at it and I started to love it and it
wasn't just one of those things where I
was like oh you know I'm cool with this
but there's there's growth there's a
place where I know I can be better at
and even early on in high school I would
watch college football almost
religiously like I used to love
University of Miami and around that time
University of Miami was like the best
football in all of the nation they had
some of the greatest players of all time
Sean Taylor Ed Reed Kellen Winslow this
everybody played in Miami and I was like
these guys are so good and so fast how
did it gets fast and she's strong and
from from then I kind of like morphed
into really learning about how to train
as an athlete even from 12 13 years old
I started to like do some research and
see oh I should get some professional
like I should actually get people that
know how to do this involved in my life
and I think sophomore year my mom
actually made a huge sacrifice and
investment in for me and hired a
strength conditioning coach so in high
school I started to take this sport
really serious I didn't take my grades
as super serious but I did enough so
that I could still play
um and maintain that like BC average but
the strength conditioning uh coaching
that I got helped improve my athletic
ability tenfold I mean like I was a
whole new player every two months every
every three months I would continue to
evolve and I was like really young and
experiencing growths and having a growth
mindset and I was like dude this is
really cool so
um developed a great relationship with
my strength conditioning coach and he
helped me continue to put the tools
together to to be in that Elite class
that I could get recognition around the
country
um then I'd say around my junior year I
said
I'm like almost done you know High
School like I'm not going to college to
become an engineer or a scientist or you
know I want to play football like I set
a goal to play football and I wanted to
do it for free I had seen the sacrifice
the hard work and and the willingness
that my mother gave to make sure I
succeeded and I wanted to pay her back
tenfold so I wanted to go to college for
free and I knew that if I put my effort
in here it'll pay off in the long run so
my junior year I went all in in the off
season and then I balled out that year I
played both ways I became you know first
in the league and I started to get
attention nationally I started getting
some college offers and letters
um started to actually get my name out
there I didn't get Miami or USC on the
radar yet but you know once a lot of
those bigger D1 schools started to call
I was like oh this this is working you
know you start seeing Virginia and Penn
State Michigan State you start seeing
these big schools Stanford they actually
are willing and want to meet me and give
me college tuition I was like this is
money this is great all right so yeah
yeah
um but even at that age I remember
wanting what I wanted I was like this is
cool I still want a scholarship from
University of Miami so
um in the summer going into my senior
year they do these like combine camps
and whatnot and uh where they bring
College scouts out and they let kids do
their tests and play seven on seven and
just show up the skills and I went there
and did you know vertical jump jump like
46 I'd skip to 40. I was like let me
just do these drills and fall out and
these kids you know I see the Scout that
I know
keep your eyes on me I go out there
seven on sevens and go do some
one-handed catches come down on one
and I hear my knee go oh my God so I'm
in the middle of the field and I just
realized like I I can't I can't move
this knee and I hobble my butt off to
the sidelines and
um try to to sneak to the the car to to
get away from here so the news wouldn't
spread but uh some of the scouts had saw
that injury occurred and uh then the
following Monday I remember I think
about like 107 colleges offered
scholarships all them off the table only
three colleges were still committed to
me after the word that I had tore my ACL
and that was uh University of Akron
Temple University in Philadelphia and
then West Virginia University in
Morgantown West Virginia so I was hurt
had to go through ACL reconstruction
surgery and was you know sidelined my
entire senior year of football
but I still had those scholarships and
you know talking to a mentor of mine and
my strong conditioning coach my family
we made the decision you know to go to
West Virginia and sign with them and I
remember like it was yesterday man
signed a college letter of intent had a
big you know signing day thing at my
college at my high school and then
January July 1st of uh 2007 I was set to
go off to West Virginia to start my
football career and it was one of the
greatest things ever you know getting to
where I wanted to be setting and setting
a goal and then planning for that goal
and then executing it it was incredible
so for you right and and always saying
this because you know we we hear this
this constant Narrative of like how
important it is to have like a you know
a two-parent unit family right do you
feel like your mom took the mantle of
both like father and mother for you did
you have another male figure in your
life that helped you along the way I had
a lot of uncles that that came around I
will say and and family friends and my
mothers um they were close and and there
were some great valuable lessons I
picked up from them but my mother was
the primary force in my life and she was
the one that provided protected as she
looked out for me however I will say
with a caveat today knowing and now
especially now being a father that that
my mother could only do so much there's
only so much in her abilities to teach a
person to be who they are called to be
and specifically with being a man I I do
look back on and I'm grateful for the
ways that she did teach me and the
lessons I've learned
um but I know also my life would be so
different if my father was around I
could have learned a lot of different
skills that I've had to pick up on later
on in life so
um would I have changed the way my life
would be honestly no I I really think
all of the things that have happened to
me happened for a reason and a purpose
and a lot of times I don't ever get to
know what that is I can look back in
hindsight and see how that season or
that that struggle challenged me or
taught me something I even take a quote
from Jalen hurt yesterday losing you
know there's you win or you get a lesson
learned and and you know sometimes those
lessons that are learned hurt they are
painful they can be challenging and even
scarring and um you know I look back on
my life in hindsight and I'm like I'm
really grateful for the way that God has
used these things to shift me and to
mold me and I know I'd be a totally
different person if I had my father
around and my mother wasn't that primary
person or you know she might not have
even gone to an Ivy League school or
started a business what do you so your
father you know he passed away when he
was when you were eight so what do you
remember of him my dad was a gentle
loving man
um ironically I got to have my dad in
the last years of his life
um he had already you know had two
previous marriages and had two other
kids so I have a brother and sister who
I love very much and uh get to still do
life with them
um but he was a nice awesome man I just
keep saying nice because that's the
thing that I always he was gentle kind
uh lowly in heart he would literally I
mean I think the last few years of his
life he became a pescetarian and tried
to stop drinking beer and stopped
smoking cigarettes and he was just
trying to change his life and do better
um and I remember that he would do
whatever it would to make sure that I
was happy and the times that I had him
so he was interesting like
I think we don't really think about this
until we get older where
um when I was younger I remember my
parents would talk about how important
it is to have a strong family unit right
and for some reason as a kid whenever
your parents tell you something you
always I don't know if it's like me
being like this this kid with a chip on
my shoulder right like this young
like you always think the worse are
sometimes the things that your parents
say so I'm like oh what are you talking
about you know people who don't have
like a strong structured family they're
still good people that's not what they
were saying but you as a kid you're so
defensive you just want to argue with
everything yeah and then what they were
trying to tell me now that I'm older is
like there are things that happen to you
when you are younger within your family
life that will affect you as an adult
whether it's good or it's bad right so
these things are things that you should
think about when you you know end up
having your family or you have a kid
like how how these factors will affect
the Next Generation that that comes up
within I didn't realize that stuff until
you know honestly probably even like
seven or eight years ago where
um a lot of my interpersonal
relationships with like men and women
who grew up in really kind of [__] up
family lives that I knew about right and
I start seeing these odd behaviors that
are similar with every person that
didn't grow up with certain figures in
their lives right A lot of my female
friends who didn't grow with the male
figure in their life they all went
through the
and I want to say all because I really
think of like six or seven of them yeah
same issue right where all of us as
friends have had this conversation with
them where they had this perception and
a view of what a man is when they never
had a stable man in their life right
this is what a man is supposed to do
yeah this is what men should do and you
know it's like where did you get this
from you know why don't you read that
what TV show did you see this example
from exactly like the idea of men being
you know vulnerable that you know having
these times of weakness where you know
we we can't take care of everything we
are not we are Partners here I am not
your father Yes and this is this is like
a shift that a lot of them later on some
of them did some of them didn't right um
obviously I'm not going to say their
names let's call her Jenny all right so
my friend Jenny too we actually I
wouldn't say it was an argument but it
was a disagreement and she gets very
sensitive about the subject because she
has gone cycled through so many
relationships with men and I and I asked
her
because she was dating one of my good
friends okay and they broke up and when
they broke up she was crying to me about
the guy or whatever because I actually
kind of hooked them up together and I
knew where he was coming from because
he's my good friend and she
I I realized with with her what she was
equating
um what she wanted out of a man was more
of what she wanted out of a father
you know so I was like what what didn't
you like about his name is Billy or
something what did you like about Billy
right from under the bus yeah so she was
like well like I did everything for him
like I you know I cooked I cleaned all
these like traditional trucks you see of
what it means to be a strong woman right
but I knew what Billy wanted out of a
partner and he wanted it equal he wanted
somebody who was motivated that would
wake up with the goal in mind and what
she wanted was listen I want you to go
out there make money and make all this
money in the world so I could just sit
at home and you know I like suck your
dick or whatever the [__] it is it's
like listening
and the funny thing was is that she
didn't know that right and when I was
talking to him and what he told me was
was yeah she equated her being a good
partner to me by like oh whenever you
want to have sex we'll have sex or
you'll cook me some type of meal he goes
I can go buy food right I want to know
that the last argument that they had was
hey like what are your plans what are
you going to do today you know you
probably do have plans but like what's
the thing that makes you tick what's the
thing that the only thing she responded
to often was like don't ever [__]
question what I [__] do like I'm a
self-sufficient woman blah blah blah and
he goes whoa and then he kind of he
broke up with her after that I
understand and I clearly understand and
it wrecked her and then our conversation
was like listen I know him and I heard
about the argument that you had and she
and she explained the argument the same
way he did but how she feels about it
was different she was can you believe
him I was like yeah I believe him I was
like you you are equating your value as
a woman it's it's very interesting like
we are in a time now where we have
Partnerships that are mutually
beneficial right
when you value yourself as a woman as
like oh I suck dick really good blah
blah blah cool that's fine that's that's
the bonus that's a great attribute oh
that's great that's not what he wanted
in a partner and what he wants in a
partner is what he sees out of his
household what he saw his mom do she was
she was a woman that sucked it up again
she was she she ran her business with
her husband but she held [__] down in
the house and the dad it was something
Mutual you wanted to fulfill a part that
albeit you will find a man that
appreciates that out of you but it
wasn't what he wanted right but once
again she was saying that he's not a man
blah blah blah like he doesn't want to
provide for me and I'm like oh this is
this is where the difference is and I
saw the same Trope with like five or six
other homegirls who also grew up with
fathers who went to prison uh fathers
who left them before they even knew who
they were so their identity of what what
a man is was a little is something they
had to create in their head rather than
the personal experience they grew up
with at home
well I think also again the expectations
there were clearly not communicated in a
relationship there's something obviously
I don't know the relationship to that
personal extent but it was interesting
hearing two of this two same stories
yeah two different interpretations Hey
listen that's the cool part about and I
I love all people and I can respect
everybody's opinion we're all entitled
to them
um but again like I said earlier man
like people's opinions sometimes will
have consequences and again if you don't
communicate what your expectation is in
a relationship in a job place there's
going to be a gap between where you
might fall short where there will be
some feelings that come in the way of
what the facts are and I'm I'm big on
communicating the expectation and um I
really I'm grateful for my spouse me and
my wife have really huge communication
expectations for our relationship and it
works out and
um I didn't get a chance to see that
with my mother and my father and it's
it's a miracle to me somehow that
um at least my wife says this that I'm a
great husband and a great dad and I
didn't get to see either of those things
really take place not only in my my
father my mother but even in the people
around I didn't have
um a perf again there's no perfect
parent there's no perfect father no
perfect man however uh just seeing
people that are doing good and trying is
is a great benefit for a young person to
witness and to have that experience
um and you know to my mother's credit I
got to see what a great woman does in a
great business person and someone that
will position themselves to have options
and do everything to sacrifice for their
children and and that is you know
Priceless I'm so grateful for that um
but you know again life would be so
different if if everybody had the
perfect mother and father at home yeah
if everybody grew up in a two-parent
home maybe our world would be different
but uh I know that that's not the way
the world is and I'm not going to expect
the World to Change right now yeah and I
think like the real positive thing is
like you know once again
with the with the few of those homegirls
who you know who've had like that not
having that male figure in their life
later on as they went through therapy
they figured out like okay maybe my
expectation of what I expect out of a
man is a little you know far-fetched
right yeah and so
um yeah they the the ability to kind of
look what look at what you lack in your
life and they kind of change it is is a
good ability to have right because none
of us are nowhere near being perfect
right so I I always find it to be a red
flag when somebody says hey
um this might be a problem that we have
in the media it's like [__] you it's
like oh hold on a second you know if
it's somebody that you care about that
you guys want to have a good
relationship with it would be a good
idea for you to hear themselves out
right and I used to have this quality
like I just mentioned when I was younger
and even now with my relationship with
my wife sometimes like when her feelings
are hurt because of the things that I
say because you know I'm a clown I joke
around a lot and I and I forget
sometimes you know she's not a boy
they
it cut deep and I look at her and then
she's upset or I look at her like how I
look at some of the guys like when they
say something stupid I'm like what the
[__] are you talking about but I can't
talk to her that way and then you know
that happened the other day where I
looked at I was like oh make any [__]
sense what are you talking about and she
goes you look at me really
disrespectfully and I'm like I want to
be like that and I looked and I was like
oh I'm not excuse me you just did it
again and I'm like what are you talking
about she goes you're doing it right now
and I had to stop and think I'm like oh
I'm talking to her like she's like one
of the boys and then I have to say I'm
sorry and I apologize that's so good man
and those are words that I never heard
in my household and so even then for me
it's hard to say it but I know that if I
feel it I should express it yeah because
it's my pride and my ego getting in the
way so good bro that's such a growth
mindset to have it's and I'm telling you
it's hard like you don't grow up hearing
people say I'm sorry or I love you or or
I love you or this this was my fault
what so crazy or that offended me but I
still love you and I think it's I'll
I'll be you know down right I'll
honestly say it like after my father
passing away I remember years years of
my life that I struggled with anger I
struggled with unforgiveness not only at
the person who murdered him uh but even
like to God like why would you take my
dad away like you know I was one of
those young people that I'm like yo if
God is good like why would bad things
happen like now I know bad things happen
all the time to all people and it's
going to be okay sometimes really bad
things end up working for good in the
long run I think tragedy sometimes ends
up bringing a lot of Hope in the long
run there's things that get turned
around from terrible situations and
circumstances that end up being some of
the greatest things in people's lives
um and again like me tearing my ACL
the first time was was that okay the
first time
right segue right back to that trash uh
tearing my ACL the first time was
damaging to me as a young teenager that
wanted to do something and go somewhere
and then that opportunity was stopped
couldn't do it in hindsight now it's the
best decision that ever could have
happened for me not going to a place
where hey I would have never played I
was never going to play at Miami or USC
uh and then B I probably would have had
a terrible experience and I would not be
or where I'm at today
um and also again tearing your ACL the
first time prepares you for the second
time uh because once I got to college
and you know played uh through one whole
entire summer of training and getting
ready for the season tore my ACL in the
last practice get the [__] out of here
same name uh similar situation going up
in the air trying to catch the ball
coming down Landing improperly tearing
it so I had to go through a second
surgery in college
um and then I thought I was done I
thought I was I thought I was done you
know two ACLS recover cool went through
the reconstructive surgery went through
all the rehab nine months later back on
the field doctors give you the clearance
they give me the go ahead go do your
thing go hustle you know in the time my
college and my uh my coaches were still
kind caring so still took me in and
still saw me as a project to work on for
years and being an asset so they kept my
scholarship they had faith in me and my
work ethic to get back to not only 100
but to be better than I was prior to
that
um and then I get out go through a whole
spring training and on the very last
practice at the very last
workout train my AC on the third time
so three times I I had my right
ACL do you just feel at a certain point
God is just like listen I can't keep
giving you signs this is not for you
this is not yours okay listen I tore
your ACL three times and if you still
don't get it by now I I I'm I guess I'm
a little hard-headed you know uh my mom
says that I didn't get the humble Gene
and I'm hard-headed sometimes and maybe
I can't take a sign sometimes but uh
after tearing it the third time uh I
will say that's when my life changed
really really tragically in a sense um
you know losing my father was one uh
tearing ACL and you know not being able
to play the thing that you love and have
just dedicated the last 10 years of your
life a little closer to you yeah taking
the last 10 years of my life to just
dedicate the football and it not being a
part of my life was TR was hard it was
hard for me to deal with
um but then I I would say I didn't get
to go to the Bowl game
um they played in the Meineke Car Care
Bowl that year I think against North
Carolina and I got to go back to back
home it was cool I got to spend time
with my family and experience Christmas
and then things were going well and then
January 9th 2009 driving back to West
Virginia with a friend of mine from high
school who had gone to the same college
with me uh we were just going back to
our school
um about an hour and a half outside of
West Virginia in Maryland uh we were
driving along the highway I think it was
the 17 705 and um I started to drive on
some ice and my car started to slide on
the highway about 300 yards and I don't
really have too much control but I'm
trying to slow it down and we literally
crash into an embankment on the hill
um me and my friend we look at each
other and we're fine we're like oh that
was a miracle we
called the police we called our parents
I called AAA because once we got out the
car we saw that the only damage that had
happened was my tire had been knocked
off the rim so I was like
call the tow truck we'll be back to
campus in like two hours no problem
um I look at my friend and we're
standing outside of my truck
um you know on the side of the highway
and I just remember looking like wow
that's crazy that that just happened and
then that was that was the last thing
that I remember
um a vehicle slid on the same patch of
ice
and then had hit me hit my friend and
then hit my car
and I was knocked unconscious when I
woke up hold on you were outside of the
car inside the car we were outside of
the car and you got hit by a car you got
hit by a car get the [__] out of here I
actually uh it's a miracle that I'm
alive and I'll say you know I I don't
understand how things work and why but
um I I had got hit so hard I had my
iPhone in my front pocket and this is
like thank thank God we called the
police and we called our parents at that
moment because when I woke up I no
longer had shoes on I no longer had
socks on my phone that was in my pocket
and my friend I tried to pull it out and
the iPhone literally was bent around my
quad like this so the iPhone smashed
broken I wouldn't have been able to call
and communicate to anybody
um I see glass I See Fire debris our car
and our luggage is just scattered all
throughout the highway
um and then my friend was eight inches
away from my face face down on the side
of the Hill
um barely breathing and I saw the car
that had hit us he was now facing
oncoming traffic and he couldn't get out
of his vehicle so in that moment in
some sort of panic I ended up rolling my
friend over giving him CPR until he
could breathe again
um I I he was yelling at the person who
had hit us to to call for help call the
police and I just remember him yelling
that he couldn't he was stuck he
couldn't get out and then
I like
hobble up onto my feet and I'm stumbling
through glass and I just see his door
bent all the way in and then I just grab
him and pulled him through the window
um and then run back over to my friend
and um just then the police pulled up
from the first time we call it they
showed up
um one of the officers helped stabilize
my friend bring him down and then they
called the paramedics paramedics came
and took him to the hospital
um and then they dealt with me and the
other person who had hit us
um I was was fine by all accounts as far
as injuries go
um had some bruising some scarring here
and there
um but my friend had I think a broken
elbow broken arm he had a a really bad
wound in the back of his head and he was
bleeding and um they ended up taking him
to John Hopkins
um
we were in the hospital together that
night for a little bit and um and then
they transported him to another place I
believe uh I I stayed up in that
hospital all night long
in pain to a degree
um but psychologically broken uh blaming
myself believing that I
should have been that person I should be
the one that can't breathe or I I should
it should have been me there not the
other way around and um I remember that
night experiencing symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder and
Nightmares and Terrors and
um you know about two weeks later on
that two weeks from that that incident
my friend unfortunately passed away
and um that's when uh my life I remember
changed that that season of darkness and
pain uh like engulfed me and I
experienced the worst depression of my
life I experienced night terrors all day
long I ended up actually uh in that
season trying to you know be normal and
I just couldn't I remember uh just
trying to drown the pain in any way I
could possible and months and months and
months of struggle and eventually it was
like I couldn't even keep my focus in
class and I literally went from like a
3.8 student to failing every single
class I failed every single class I was
not I wasn't there who I was as a human
being and um man
yeah that that car accident
changed my life and uh changed the lives
of a lot of people
um but but now again I just look back
hindsight it's 2020 and you can see
change and fruit
I'm so grateful for
um
of being alive and do you ever look back
at that situation and think like
you know because you said earlier that
you know you felt like it should have
been you instead what made you think
that
I was the the older one I was the one
driving uh I I me and me and my friend
had drove plenty of times we had taken
that trip like eight to nine times like
we had done a lot of time and I was
always driving I was always caring for
this kid and like taking care of his
needs and the fact that again that like
his family entrusted me to take him to
back to school you know I was like I
just felt responsible I felt guilty I
felt like if anyone should have been
tragically injured in that night it
should have been me
um you know I couldn't have controlled
that person that hit us
um we thought we were safe we thought we
were doing the right thing and uh you
know it wasn't
you know you're never prepared for
tragedy you never prepared for incidents
like this and as a young kid being in a
hospital bed and hearing
your friend being worked on by multiple
Physicians just with a curtain next to
you and they're looking at you like how
how are you and him in the same the same
thing how are you in the same incident
this doesn't make any I couldn't make
any sense of it that I looked down and I
just see a few scratches scrape scars
but nothing broken Nothing Hurt here
like I'm physically still here uh my
friends unconscious and so that was a
really
tough thing for me to hear in the fight
through was he also an athlete too he he
played football on the same team with me
in high school but he did not he was an
athlete in college he was a regular
student a good regular student and um I
am you know he's always in my heart and
forever and he's one of the reasons why
I did eventually get back to school and
get my excuse me get my scholarship and
graduate um in his memory and honor and
you know it is you know even bringing up
the story still brings pain it still
brings hurt yeah and that's intense it
was it was and um yeah I would love to
say that the story was all cheery and
happy in in the months after that uh I
started getting the therapy I needed and
Recovery was smooth and it wasn't it was
years of struggle trial of getting help
and having
um the vulnerability uh to get out and
to actually reach out for help and to
start seeing a therapist to start
letting people know that I was dealing
with some really dark stuff for a long
time and uh now I can see that that it
was a season in my life that that grew
me and has helped me to be able to
overcome adversity in a lot of ways
because
um even after losing my scholarship
after that season you know I fought for
that I had to go through
um a lot of appeal courts because the
university didn't want to knew my
scholarship anymore they're like you're
Dungey because you got to keep up the
grades and you got to be an athlete you
know I had to go through so many rings
and uh Hoops to actually fight for West
Virginia University to getting back my
scholarship and I finally was able to
and they gave me my full ride back and I
was able to finish the last two and a
half years of college and graduate with
a sports exercise psychology degree
um but yeah it was a step in in the
story of my life and I'm excited to now
share with with you and with with people
all around the world about it man you
know it's so interesting because like
you know for you you in your case
like I'm always curious about people who
like how how does that transition happen
right because you know we we mentioned
this before the podcast was recording
how there is a certain rhetoric that's
happening now with a lot of young people
because social media is full of young
people's thoughts right and when you're
young you have to understand we were in
my 20s and my teens I was a full-blown
[__] idiot everything that I thought
and felt was facts whether it was
feelings or not you know and sometimes
when you have a whole group of people
that kind of push that narrative that
you're trying to push even when it's
wrong at the moment you feel like you're
always right right so you know for you
as a young person to go through that
and kind of push yourself out of this
type of adversity that a lot of people
don't feel right they don't experience
these type of crazy things and like I'm
curious in your in your perspective of
how you were able to shift yourself and
not blame your circumstance for where
you're at now because it's very easy
because I've done that at a young age
right where I'm like okay if I if only I
had a little more money if I wasn't so
[__] poor if I wasn't this this and
that I would never be in these
situations right in your case I mean you
lost your father your father was
murdered
um your mother had a how to take the
reins and and raise you you had your you
you focused your life through your
mother's positive influence and even
then through that Focus you had the
injury that was taking that got taken
from you you recollected yourself and
then you got injured again and then you
got injured again and then this happened
so how did you compartmentalize all this
stuff and somehow shift yourself into
being the person you are now very good
um you can't always deal uh you can't
actually control the hand that you're
done life and I think from a young age
and losing my father I experienced I
found that out oh like I want to have my
dad but look he's he's actually not
coming back like cool so I'm
experiencing dissonance here with what I
want and what I'm actually seeing in
life and realizing yo like I don't play
the you don't control everything but
how you handle the situation is is a
huge Testament to who you are as a
person and I've learned to realize I'm
not going to control everything or every
person but I can control my effort I can
control my mannerisms I can be upset and
angry or or offended
but I still have to show up I still have
things to do I still have
responsibilities and you know I will
again say like my mother taught me very
much well as a young child to be
responsible to do the things that you
have to do before to do the things that
you want to do and that just kind of
stuck with me all the time like yeah I
want to play football but right now I I
can't I'm hurt I got to patiently put
myself in a position
um I understood like I would be nice if
I had more money it'd be nice if I was
faster or taller or I was less prone to
injury but I can't do that so if I still
want to be successful I still want to
accomplish things I'm going to have to
navigate and shift and change uh the
trajectory of my life right now and I
think most of it comes from the
perspective of your mind everything
starts here and if you can shift your
perspective of what's actually happening
you can do a lot with it you know like I
said if you see a loss as just oh this
is a loss this is a failure and your
mindset goes to that you're going to
take it as a failure and you're not
going to actually grow or evolve from
that but if you take these things and
you see this is this is a moment for me
to grasp what I did wrong and then
change it to what I want to do right
here's a moment where I fell short here
what can I do to improve myself on the
next day the next month the next year
and I think having a mindset of always
wanting to be better is is hopefully
again everybody would have that if you
want to keep getting better you won't
let adversity you won't let failures you
won't let these losses take you out for
so long now I I'll be real when when the
car accident happened when I went
through that that terrible season in my
life I didn't have a positive outlook on
life I wasn't growing I was actually
shrinking back I was dying I was I was
literally doing everything I could to
kill myself I think yeah between food
alcohol drugs like I was not living and
trying to numb everything I was trying
to numb any kind of pain because again
like I would be in the middle of class
and then I'll just close my I want to
enclose my eyes I would just look over
to the right and then I remember like a
vivid HD 4K 180 video replay of that
night would happen and I would like
freak out and panic and like I had to
like run out having a panic attack wow
and I I can't lie and say that you know
it took me days or weeks it was months
and years of work and actually having to
be in those in that Darkness
um and you know I really I really credit
God to pulling me out of that like I
remember getting saved in that season in
my life praying and saying God if you're
real show up like putting God to the
test about
if he's good and whatnot and again I
don't want to get into a a too deep
topic about religion but I truly believe
that God works all things for a purpose
and again we don't need to know what the
purpose is ultimately if we do our job
if we're diligent if we are good
stewards of our time our talent and our
treasure uh will be rewarded for that
and sometimes it's not the way we look
at it the the the objective and the goal
and the way you're going to be at is not
anywhere where you think it's going to
be like again I thought I would be
playing in college and then I thought
easy go to the NFL that's an easy dream
in place where I want to be at I would
have no idea I had no idea that the plan
was for me to end up taking a 180 and
moving into boxing and now for boxing to
be a career of mine and something that
I'm passionate about and a hobby and you
know when I was in that Darkness I would
say some random things happened that
kind of set me up to do that like being
on campus at West Virginia and then
seeing a flyer for boxing trials like
boxing
okay I mean I love the sport I used to
watch it growing up like it wasn't on
all the time but I remember when there
was a pipe Pay-Per-View fight with Mike
Tyson I was there I remember watching
Floyd Mayweather Prince Naseem Hamed I
had watched these fights Prince Nasi
come on man one of my favorites of all
time
I would watch these but I was never
trained formally in it I was never like
oh that's the I should do that
I saw boxing as this Elite Pinnacle of
athletic prowess and
when I saw that tryout I showed up and I
fell in love the very first day I just
saw the flyer showed up the coach had a
workout and had a team and you know I
had you know I guess been like nine or
ten months removed from playing football
so I was still an athlete I was still
6'2 215 maybe I might have been 220
because I put on some weight after that
season of life and you know but I I
found a natural knack to box and I also
found myself while training in that in
that room that my mind was here
I'm not thinking about the pain from the
past I'm not thinking about my failures
I'm not worried about anything else I'm
present right now and that that opened
my eyes up in so many ways so then
literally Tuesday Thursday I would start
training and I was like oh this is good
this is great
what happens if I want to get a little
better like oh well I mean you can train
on other days of the week you can work
with some other coaches I had to start
to ball with it and like within six
months I competed in my first fight but
like 4-0 and I was just knocking people
out I ain't gonna lie I definitely think
I was raging off of some anger issues in
the first couple fights and just black
out and then have my hand raised like
what happened yeah that's what happened
he's down he's still down he's dead I
was like I was like that when I first
started yeah you know I was raw I was
ugly I think some of one of my first
fights is actually up on YouTube right
now still
um not pretty but I was enjoying myself
I was having fun and I was finding a
purpose in something that I was doing it
wasn't the all purpose of everything and
I didn't see it as this is my career
right now but it was becoming fun it was
a hobby it was something that I started
doing and competing like oh this is cool
so I started to compete in amateurs at
West Virginia and then I was part of
that team started to go and seen some
tournaments I was at West Point a couple
times started to get into these National
tournaments and boxing just became
everything to me I I became immersed in
it started studying some of the great
started watching uh the the hagglers the
Hearns the Pacquiao's I started to
actually shift my mindset and go I was a
student of the game for football
to a t that I would watch hours and
hours of film to study and prepare
myself for for games or practices even
to like just transfer this skill here
you can see so much more of the sport
and understand so much more when you
have uh a student's mind to it right I
always like to be a student of life and
when I was boxing I was like I gotta
study I gotta learn see how these people
that are great doing and then a
implicate it try it test see what it is
and that's when I also figured out that
I was a southpaw even though I am
right-handed try to say a little like
Andre Ward a little bit you know well
that's a problem for a lot of people
yeah it was it was during the amateur
days and I'm grateful for that at the
same time competing also taking on a
leadership responsibility with the team
and training other Fighters and it was
just magical I guess like I'm improving
myself I'm helping other people improve
this is great like coaching seems to be
something that I can kind of dwell in
and that was that was it bro I started
to go I started to accumulate
certifications I started to again after
I graduated started to put all my energy
into coaching and also I mean I still
competed on the side here but I knew
where my mind was at my mind was to help
people improve
not just to make me make money or not
just for me to become a great Fighter
um so I really committed myself to being
a student of the game and of the art
itself and then helping people in more
than just again timing offense and
defense but strength and conditioning
understanding training the mind because
again everything starts from there so my
career shifted to then being a strength
conditioning boxing coach and I worked
at UFC gym in LA Boxing over on the east
coast and that was a great experience
for me
um a working and doing what I love to do
but then also seeing the business side
to it and knowing
not every person is going to be a
professional fighter a lot of people
want to learn how to box and better
themselves and if they're willing to
commit and they're willing to make the
sacrifice and and be a student well why
not take them on so I started to train
dozens if not hundreds of people over in
the east coast
um and my Hunger just grew an
opportunity called for me to come and
work here on the east or on the best
coast and I transferred and came over
here to UFC Jim Torrance and uh that was
a great start for me in 2015 to start
doing what I do today which is uh not
get punched in the face yeah but still
make a lot of money off boxing and uh I
love doing what I do every day brother
that's amazing man your story is [__]
nuts dude that was actually not I did
not expect that at all
I said like as you were telling your
story I was picturing it in my head and
I was getting ptse through you I'm sorry
bro was I there you know it's it's it's
kind of crazy like when I hear what a
lot of people go through in order to
find and you know you said something
very interesting too which I think this
is what I really enjoyed about because I
started kickboxing one only like three
and a half four years ago right and
obviously my time was split so I was
doing it when I could and when I can
um but it was the idea of when you're
training a martial arts you are very
much present you why because it should
not get stuck in the face on night night
yeah so you're paying attention to this
one thing and I think like
what I also really liked about martial
arts is um the honesty and in terms of
you could talk a big game as much as you
want once you're in that little Cage The
Ring The Octagon whatever it is let's
see if you're really about that [__]
life yeah and I I I think I kind of
romanticized a lot of
I was gullible right because I never
trained like that before so whenever
somebody told me like oh I trained four
or five years boxing I'm like oh this
guy's going to be good and then I you
know you train with them like you did
cardio kickboxing for four years you
know relax oh it's like in my mind I'm
like you know like it's one of the most
honest sports ever you cannot lie
actually Sports in general are honest
like you enter into a ring of
competitors they're going to sniff you
out so [__] fast so easy you know so
easy and even for somebody like for
example there was um
one of the things I really really
disliked was you know when you come to
train especially you know you've seen
how we train we all are just a bunch of
friends too and we have a couple people
who are actual trained Fighters that
train us right and the rest we just
follow suit and we would bring some
people on who would talk a big game and
once again me being a gullible person
I'm bringing these people in like an
idiot you know I'm like oh hey this my
buddy he says he trained for x amount of
years and then we cool and we bring him
in and I'm sitting there shocked I'm
like you suck show up yeah I was like
what did you you've lied to me for so
long you know it's terrible like you're
kidding your ass beat you know and I'm
like what what was all this [__] for
what is what is this [__] for you
know leave that [__] in Hollywood man
this is a [__] there's [__]
Killers here you know real talk like
once you get into some of the amazing
MMA and boxing gyms that are throughout
this country there are some real dogs
out there bro there are some there are
some dogs that you do not want to get in
the ring with and they'll let you get a
drink with them if you have the
credentials or you're going to pay the
money and they'll teach you a lesson 399
yeah put you out on your face super
funny story I think when I came out to
LA a couple years prior to me moving
here 2013 I was still active and amateur
so I still fought here and there and um
I went to Wild Card I'm like training
with all my friends and it's a sparring
day and then this Pros are in there like
oh I mean let me hop in there like no we
don't got no heavy weights I'm like I
mean that I'm offended but but you ain't
lying you ain't lying I'm a whole 195
pounds here and then there's like this
one little Russian dude
you want to go with some rounds with him
I was like oh yeah this dude's 154
pounds 154 pound five foot three Russian
dude he hops in a ring with me and I'm
like all right his coach is looking at
me I was like go go light on him you
know take it easy on him don't jab him
too hard I'm like I can do that I can do
that I'm a heavyweight I walk over to
this dude like let's have some fun man
have a good time and he says something
to me in Russian I'm like
foreign
he comes in with his overhand overhand
right hits me like the back of my head
I'm like oh my God
me what do you mean I can't go hard how
am I going to live through this round I
gotta keep him at Bay and I just
remember like afterwards we have good
conversations we did like three rounds
this little dude hit like he was 400
pounds yeah and I'm like unknowing you
you don't know until you see it there's
so many people that are unassuming that
are just you know you can look at them
on the outside and not know that they
had that dog in them they have a little
killer inside of them and that's the
thing too like even something that's not
a fight related I remember the first uh
floor seat tickets I ever had was to a
Clippers game I have a friend a friend
who works for the Clippers and she
hooked it up I was literally four seats
there you go and you know you're
watching it from a TV screen right and
you see how athletic these people are
and then I see it where I'm on the floor
with them in person and I go I get it
you guys are not human this is why this
is you're the elite of the elite and I
was just watching it was a Blake Griffin
and fast break did a dunk I was like did
he just walk across the whole Court in
six steps okay you know basically yep
and in my mind too I'm like why are
these people just getting the [__] out
of his way when he's dunking I was like
you know why because it's like a [__]
freight train just flew in the air if
you get hit by one of those knees you're
out you're done you're dead there goes
your career you're pretty much dead and
I that was a sobering moment for me
where I'm like oh it's different from
looking at it on the screen and being
there in person they're so [__] fast
on the phone I couldn't keep my ice
cream it was like this I'm like I can't
see what's going on so I wanted to move
back more so I could see them work
because they were just too quick so I
was like oh athletes are different yeah
they are they're people who do it for
fun there's people who do it for fun fun
and there's people that that are about
that [__] life there's levels there's
levels and you find out real quick when
you get immersed in it and you see oh
I'm I'm not I'm not cut out for this
like I love when I'm just like I play
football in high school me I'm like I
play football in college I was at the
division one scholar school on a full
scholarship which I got the lead of the
elite and then I saw some of them cats
from Florida that I we're on my team
that ran like four two four three and
had like you know
everything handed dude these dudes were
stacked they were ripped they had they
had I had wide receivers that could
bench like 400 pounds and squat six I'm
like [__] this doesn't make any sense
yeah I'm we're on the same team and I'm
not on your level yeah this is why I'm
second string and I see that now and you
see it more I think in Combat Sports
than ever and that's why I'm a huge fan
of and I'm always going to be a fan of
Combat Sports as a whole boxing mixed
martial arts Jiu Jitsu even now and one
of the worst things you can see is
people that don't understand the sport
that are just watching it and going oh
man I would have threw this or that guy
took you down man just get up
have you ever wrestled or done Jujitsu
it is so hard to get a grown man off of
you like it's terrible that's why when
um I went to the it was uh Henry sahuto
versus uh Mighty Mouse oh it was his
last fight at the UFC I was the one with
Bart and uh Geo we all got tickets and I
didn't realize how stupid UFC fans are
my lovely genius farts or in Korean
pangus that's right this podcast is
brought to you by raycon my friends and
I'll tell you this this time of the
years where everybody's talking about
making big changes which is all well and
good but most of the time pretty
unrealistic and I have done that
multiple times I've said I was gonna get
a six-pack every year and I have failed
but I've gotten a little more fit every
time I've actually found that the
smallest changes to your routine can
make the biggest impact in the same way
you don't have to break the bank to make
a big deal purchase even the smallest
things can be a part of a big change if
it's something that you use every day
raycon is premium audio at the perfect
price point so you can build great
habits without breaking the bank I use
my raycons whenever I jog whenever I
work out because they're light the
charge stays for a very long time and
the sound is pretty darn good my friends
and yep raycon starts at half the price
of other premium audio Brands so stop
spending your money losing them breaking
them and by the way if you have earbuds
with cords in them what the heck are you
doing get some raycons baby well you
drive a car with a track in it too Jesus
Christ my friends I love them noise
isolation awareness mode custom gel tips
for the perfect most comfortable in-ear
fit and so much more ready to buy
something small with a big impact go to
buy raycon.com today to get 15 off your
raycon order that's by raycon.com brain
to score 15 off by raycon.com brain
and people were screaming right she's
like why are you trying to take it to
the ground just [__] knock him out oh
really like I didn't think of that
genius
they have no idea what they're doing
yeah they're they're not knocking them
out because they don't want to like what
the [__] are you talking about they
can't yeah she's moving his hands and
blocking yeah and it's a moment of
milliseconds and millimeters is this the
game like the football is a game of
inches and it certainly is Combat Sports
you can Miss A Punch by a second or by a
half an inch and it can be the
difference between you knocking your
opponent out are you having to go to
five round distance yeah and even the
age like watching Anderson Silva now I
remember I was watching the um you know
Silva fight his last few fights at the
UFC and then we were I was looking at
Silva right and I said hmm
and the BART was like what are you was
like what are you thinking I'm like I
think people are misconstruing Silva's
skill set for his age Silva's doing what
Silva does he's just a millisecond
slower now he is and so him playing
hands down his head movement because of
that millisecond of being slower because
of his age and time always gets
everybody yeah he's getting cracked now
because it was literally like when he's
slipping these hits it's just a slight
delay yeah and then he could come with
the counter but guess what when that
time Gap is closed now he's getting
cracked he has been man that's a little
that's uh don't give me some more you
know pts I love Anderson and uh one of
my greatest greatest fighters of all
time I I still will say I idolize him as
a fighter and what he's done but when I
watched him fight Izzy and it's like
watching you know this guy get beat up
like I felt bad I felt Izzy felt bad he
was like man I'm beating up my my mentor
my idol my hair I'll get that Anderson
is a really cool cat I got I've had the
pleasure of training with him a few
times and hanging out with him here in
LA and even going paintballing with him
he's a different type of Coach though
because when he when he tries to when he
coaches and says stuff to you like I'm
going to show you this floor and just
try and he does sweet as nice as coolest
guy when he speaks in his Brazilian but
then when he like shows a movie like
he's like he'll yank oh and he'll pull
he he don't have no chill yeah he has no
chill and Anderson I'm sorry if you see
this brother I still love you um I just
don't want to do any more Jiu Jitsu
lessons with you he's still Brazilian
dude um yeah no he is but I learned a
lot from him and I I don't want to say I
got a lot of injuries coming but I
definitely have felt the force yeah of
that that he's an old man now he's an
old man but he's still got it yeah he's
still got it I mean look at his kids oh
man his kids are yo his kids are great
I've sparred with them and worked with
them before I haven't in a couple years
but but both of them came and those kids
are monsters these the the younger
generation of Fighters now are [__]
nuts they get to have this plethora of
not knowledge and their [__]
fingertips now so now you have you get
to choose what you want to be yeah right
so like watching his his sons kind of
take on what his dad does but still take
Knowledge from other coaches you're
seeing like another potential onset of
an Anderson 2.0 who knows right we we
don't know what's going to happen when
they're older if they're gonna still
compete but it's kind of like there's
this other kid named Joseph Brown okay
uh young black kid Taekwondo like
Champion but Golden Gloves boxer um this
kid is disgusting oh amazing I'm
watching this kid kickbox and I was like
dude amazing and then I saw him box I
was like he's he might be a better boxer
really I gotta show you his account UFC
is going to be calling dude he knows he
might get that contract he's I give
another five six years he'll be in the
UFC That's So Dope I love that I cannot
wait I love that like the next
generation of Fighters that's coming out
like just watching them is pretty nuts
like these young people they're so more
so much more creative they don't have as
much uh closed walls now they see these
opportunities especially Jiu Jitsu like
these young Jiu Jitsu kids they're
phenoms like how did you even think of
that 17 18 black belts my son has no
choice he is doing he's got two no
choice you're doing Jujitsu and you're
an Eagles fan that's it that's it that's
it I mean I'm gonna make sure and hope
that he goes to church with us but this
boy you know all right you're doing
Jujitsu really young
um I I love that you just put that like
that they're not seeing things in a box
I think that for so for so long
especially in boxing there's been a lot
of Gatekeepers per se and a lot of
people have been kind of fixed into this
fundamental understanding of to improve
or to be a world champion it's road work
push-up setups sparring you do mint work
you do back work there are so many more
fundamental ways to involve growth in a
Combat Sports life again balance timing
reaction uh again conditioning muscle
and endurance there's so many other
things that you need to pay attention to
in order to be great and that it's being
shined on in today especially with not
being so vast and being so accessible
um you can the develop as a fighter a
lot earlier on now and then you are not
confined to these four or five trainers
and these four or five modalities of
training
um some of these kids are getting the
world's Elite Training the best things
that they can do is and then again a lot
of things are even geared towards injury
prevention training their mindset first
and how to overcome an obstacle how to
overcome an injury in the middle of the
first round or being you know not being
able to see and when I one eye or having
to you know overcome being in a southpaw
position I I think we are in an age in a
day where we're going to continue to see
evolution in these athletes in crazier
ways and you know when you're bringing
up the whole thing of you in high school
just you know where your physical
conditioning was really the the fact
that that allowed you to level up so
quickly right like let me tell you
something I hate weight training
come on brother yeah they take something
I [__] hate that [__] but listen I
understand the importance of it later on
right because when I first started
kickboxing I didn't weight train or do
[__] at all right I wouldn't I barely
wanted to stretch I was like [__] that
[__] I'm stretching's [__] whack and
then lo and behold like three or four
months in and Nick knows this like oh
what's this little tear I have in my
shoulder yeah I'm like why do I keep
tearing my [__] shoulder you know
what I mean and then Nick is on my ass
about that he goes how many times did I
tell you you have to wait train right
it's good for bone density it's good for
endurance everything and I'm just like
shut up you ain't wrong you ain't wrong
I'm the same I used to be the same way
and I I did not like it but I love the
results from it and I understood again
if you put in the hard work now you're
gonna reap from that later on in life
um and strength condition is one of
those things that every human being
should not just athletes all of us
should be lifting weights three to four
times a week but we're not most of us
are doing nothing or running maybe you
know I'm just saying the same you I'm
all about training and I'm all about
putting in the effort but also again I
think I I had a little different
understanding of it a because I got to
see the results from my effort you know
in my own growth as an athlete but then
I was you know mentored by some strength
conditioning coaches and I got to really
understand uh the anatomy of the body
and how the grow and how muscles grow
and how you can adapt and grow and
change in different seasons and you know
I gotta credit Ryan Ojeda Mike barwis
these guys were really close to me and
and really helped me learn
um and took me under my wing it took me
under their wing at some of the lowest
moments of my life and I would not be so
heavily invested in strength
conditioning
um if it wasn't for them so and you're
seeing a lot of these athletes who
really do put the time to strength and
conditioning you're seeing like the
fruits of their of their labor
especially like let's go I mean it's
already past a few weeks but there was
the Islam and uh volkanovsky fight I'm
not saying that because when this comes
out of course but look at look at how
much the endurance mattered in their
fight it was insane it was like high
intensity chess battle bro like I like
even now right if I wanted just if I'm
short on time I want to get a quick
workout I get the fight Camp back yeah I
hit the timer five minutes let's go and
then all of a sudden I look at the time
I'm like it had to be five minutes and
it's two minutes and I'm like okay how
the [__] 2 30. you still got 20 to go
I'm sitting there just like somebody
stopped time like somebody's cheating
who the [__] stop time how the [__] is
this two minutes like I'm dying you know
what I mean sorry bro I'm just glad that
you're hitting the bag I'm glad that
you're you're still training with fight
Camp because you know you can train with
me for five minutes makes the day but
you should be stretching beforehand oh
so now like stretching is everything so
uh I so I I [__] up my ankle real bad
playing basketball when I was in college
and it's just I I have like maybe 70
mobility in it right
because I stretched I got maybe about 80
more Mobility for me I've I've only had
like 60 Mobility because of the torn
meniscus and I tried to rehab as much as
I can but I can eat the surgery now talk
to a doctor he goes it's pretty good but
you're gonna need surgery if you want to
be able to sit on your knee yeah so I'm
like okay so it's a full bucket tear so
we found that out through an MRI I
understand but the the stretching and
the strength conditioning in and of
itself already helped me when I was when
I was boxing because you just moved
better yeah you know like you move
faster move quicker who doesn't who
doesn't want me better that's the whole
thing and in order to make progress like
that people oh you do you do the work
you do the the movements yes but you can
improve the joints the muscles the bones
behind the movement to improve on a
whole another level and yeah like you
said earlier father times undefeated and
we see Anderson you know lose and we see
maybe even LeBron but clearly
you can defy it you can delay it you can
put the effort in now to help the
longevity of your life throughout them
so I'm adamant about that I'm adamant
about getting you to do some strength
conditioning because I know it's going
to benefit those injuries and it's going
to benefit you in a whole lot of other
ways yeah every day now so uh it's
uh I do I do a little weight training
every day it's all the [__] that I hate
to which yeah the reason why I started
doing the things that I hate is because
of David Goggins like this guy I loved
it I take a little percentage of his
crazy I just need a little bit of it
right and it's the idea of mentally
fortifying yourself with the things that
you hate that you know that are good for
you right yes like there's many ways
that I could get cardio done right but
guess what I hate running okay so I
guess what I'm doing I'm running now
right because I'm trying to harden my
mind and it really does help me when I
do other things too where the
application of doing things that you
don't like when it benefits you helps
you and all the other things that you
needed to improve on and it's been
really great like even every day no
matter how [__] tired I am I go into
that [__] gym and I have a set list
of the things that I have to get done
today right stretch for half an hour hit
this back 15 minutes and it doesn't take
a lot of time yeah and even if I don't
have that time moment I have to get it
done throughout the day so if if it's
going to be okay we got those landmine
squats in
um you have to hit a meeting about 10
minutes cool knocking two sets there you
go right and then finish the third set
later tonight you know I love that
mindset bro and so you know it's it's
tough like I'm not gonna lie it's tough
like I kind of [__] up I you know this
Saturday after the volklanovsky fight I
thought it was a UFC fighter
[Music]
you know
sometimes it happens that's why it's
always good to be you know motivated
stay irrelevant watch some things maybe
you might you don't know you might watch
a fight and then the next day go I'm
gonna go to the boxing gym but you said
it really well you write it down you put
it in a position where it sucks but it's
going to make me better and I I think
overcoming and hardening your mind then
it translates to everything in your life
and the moment we stop doing that that
translates to everything in our lives
the moment we get soft the moment we get
weak the moment we don't hold ourselves
accountable and do the responsible
things is when we start giving in to
Temptation a little more it starts it
starts getting a whole lot easier to go
and to not do anything and and you know
I've done that in my life I've gone
through that season and once you go
through that season enough you can
sometimes come through it and realize I
can't do that g i I will not sit back
and just not live you know and again
everybody goes through a different
struggle everyone's going through a
battle that we might not have any idea
about it so I think there's always a
space and a place to give people Grace
and we should and we should be loving
the people because their battle might be
harder or darker than anyone we've ever
gone through uh however at the end of
the day because we are responsible for
our own lives
um setting that standard and doing the
hard things is something that everyone
should do yeah it sucks but you're gonna
get better yeah it sucks it's going to
hurt but the people that are around you
are counting on you to do that yeah my
buddy Matt he owns his brand um it used
to be called uh hate brand but now it's
called not dead yet and he has this uh
he does so he was a a Highlands game
competitor you know okay
um you know he was an athlete himself
but he has this thing where he always
posts he goes I he counts the weeks that
he has left before he dies right and he
goes I I have a general idea of how many
weeks I'm going to live and I'm going to
make sure that I live to my utmost
potential every day before this number
is done and so that hearing that because
nobody really wrestles with the idea of
mortality until it's too late okay
what's close until you see it yeah we we
have a limited limited time on this
Earth what you do while you have the
time here now while you're healthy
really matters it does right whether
it's not only just for yourself but for
the people that you care about around
you too you know and I didn't realize
that until like you know maybe seven or
eight years back right it was just a
sobering moment of looking at my parents
and they were old yeah I was like oh
time has passed through right and
they're not going to be here forever and
even for you know somebody like
like like my wife right there might be a
time where I pass before she passes
before me so the time that I have here
is very very important and I think that
kind of motivates you in a different way
so when now when you wake up you wake up
with purpose it goes okay what am I
going to do from the moment I open my
eyes
till I shut my eyes and the next day I
started all over again making the days
count brother yeah and if and it feels
good and you know I think sometimes too
people people ask the same questions on
this podcast they go how what what
motivates you it's like just life in
general life this moment right now
motivates me I I I love that you said
that I got to connect with your boy
because me and him seem like we're on
the same mindset the same Vibe with that
because I I wake up like that I I have
it tattooed ingrained in my my arm again
no excuses no regrets to not make an
excuse and to not live life with regrets
rather again something was painful or
hurtful or even damaging you can use
that and learn a lesson from it and each
of us every single one of us has been
given a different lot in life but we all
had the same exact eighty six thousand
four hundred seconds every single day to
do what we can do with it you and me and
LeBron and Bill Gates and Oprah we all
got the same day yeah we were different
Lots different Lifestyles different
different attributes but but
there's nothing different about us
getting a day how we utilize it is is up
to us and I think from a perspective
where I used to waste time uh and I have
wasted seasons in my life and not done
my best to maximize my day I never want
to do that ever again yeah and you know
I stayed a million times on the podcast
one thing you guys have to understand is
that there's a few one thing guaranteed
in life is that you will die and the
other thing is you never get back this
time every second that passes by there's
nothing that you can do ever that'll get
you that time back it just goes it life
goes on whether you you choose to go on
with it or not life will always go on
dwelling on things doesn't get anything
done people sometimes get a [__] hand
dealt to them yeah right that's true and
I think like for me too and I you know
obviously for you when we dwell on these
things man like and then the moment that
you snap out of it what do you think
about [__] I wish I would have done more
with that time yeah but it's gone now
right so I could sit there and dwell on
that [__] or I could just move the [__]
on and go exactly and go you know I I do
and I think you know life is a great
lesson and it teaches us but we had we
have to learn it we have to make the
adaptation and step into it and I want
to always encourage people I want to
encourage you and and your listeners and
everybody else that you are responsible
for you no one's coming to save you so
if you want to do something in life you
have to do it make the necessary
sacrifices and steps in your life to
plan pray prepare and then execute it
and if and if you fail get up and try
that steps again go after it No One's
Gonna just hand you the job opportunity
you want No One's Gonna just you know
say yeah I'll marry you know you have to
go out and if you want to do you want to
date that girl go ask her step out of
your comfort zone and stop being okay
being inside yourself comfortable and
not letting life bother you again and if
you want something you go out and do it
and I'm all about making the opportunity
available but you have to position
yourself to have options and to do the
best you can do because again you can't
there's only so much you can say and
blame your parents or your grandparents
for the way they set up their lives that
impacted you because
they're not here they're not in your
moments they're not doing what you can
do to improve your life so
um I I'm never going to blame my parents
my grandparents or anybody in my life
around for what's happening in me you
know yeah and you know the typical
typical response that probably I'll hear
from a lot of people who tend to be very
pessimistic is you know that's easy for
you to say you don't know what I'm going
through it's like that's true but you
don't know what I'm going through either
that's so true right but I'm not putting
that on you and you shouldn't put that
on me the the idea that when somebody
I'm not saying that they're checking you
per se but they're giving you
perspective and your response is that oh
you're minimizing how I feel no I'm
saying feel how you feel but eventually
you got to get the [__] over it right
like I'm telling you feel how you
[__] feel it is within your right to
feel sad when [__] up [__] happens but
you're gonna have to deal with it and
it's not my responsibility it's not your
parents responsibility anybody else to
dig you out of the hole that you're in
right now even if you didn't dig that
hole yourself right right and a lot of
people are there a lot of people are
dealing with the the choices that
another person made and we're in a world
where that's understandable a parent
makes a messed up decision or moves a
family in another place yeah you're
gonna have to deal with with that
decision that they made but that's not
every decision in the in your life you
can still change you can still grow you
can still be successful you can still
come from a single parent home you can
still overcome adversity and be great
and and the only person that's going to
do it is you and I've I've definitely
learned to cut out certain people in the
last few years who have who always have
this rhetoric of oh woe is me why is my
life like this even when their life is
good and I can't be around that anymore
especially now I'm thinking about you
know people I get closer to the people
that I get know I don't want you to be
around these people because you're going
to suck the life out pull you down man
yeah so I can't have you around anymore
and for them they're just thinking see
people leave me but you take no personal
responsibility in the energy that you
put out we don't got to be around for
that [__] you know you know there's some
people that you can love from a distance
and yeah it's a hard conversation
sometimes especially if you had
Longevity if you've had a longer
relationship with somebody but but you
see them again pulling themselves down
pulling other people down speaking
nonsense like those are the type of
people that you don't want to have in
your life and I think the breakup is is
hard but it's a loving thing to be
honest to somebody even if that
conversation will be hurtful to them
because if you don't say it either
no one's going to no one's going to tell
this person that they're a terrible
person and that they need to change some
things unless you bring this up to them
a lot of people I'm including myself you
know we don't ever look in the mirror we
don't see who we truly are we don't take
the time to reflect we don't take the
time to understand
what ticks what makes us who we are and
you know sometimes there are some people
that you have to cut out around you
because they're influencing you in the
wrong way yeah and those destructive
people will tear you down and we've
we've you know in my one of my circles
that we had to cut this one person out
because this person literally said as we
all confronted this person it was and
she wanted to you know confront us
and it was to the point where everybody
had the same story but this person and
it's like oh all of you are crazy so
eight people are crazy but you're the
only sane one make that make sense yeah
you know make this make that make sense
to me all eight people have the same
story but you so we're all crazy so
we're all against you like that makes
absolutely no sense and the person that
the last straw was when this person was
screaming at the top of their lungs I
have done nothing wrong I have done like
like repetitively I have done nothing
wrong I have done I was like oh you're
done that sounds very narcissistic very
narcissistic very uh just the the sense
of personal responsibility is zero and
you are somebody I cannot be around
because apology is not in your blood it
is not in your system and it's not
something that you could ever do that's
sad so you know that person ended up
losing all of us and at the end of the
day and the funny thing is such a small
world so you can hear the stuff that
they say about you after right and it's
like okay I hear what you're saying and
then people will ask so I had a friend
who is a mutual friend of ours okay and
he was like yo that person said this and
this and this about you it's like what
do you think about that I was like
that's okay they're allowed to think
that I was like I'll say this about this
person I want this person to be happy
because the more happy they are the less
they [__] with us when you are satisfied
in your own life you don't try to tear
the people down so I have I have no ill
will towards this person I want them to
do well so they'll shut the [__] up and
be happy
hey you gotta you gotta wish well upon
your loved ones and even wish well upon
your enemies yeah because imagine if
your enemies are happy they don't [__]
with you because they're happy leaving
you alone yeah they lead you the [__]
alone and I I remember when I said that
this person had a light in their head
they go home something's different how
come your story is so different from
theirs I was like because once one
person's being honest and the other
person isn't clear you know I was like
listen you do whatever you want but when
we have a conversation we don't speak
about that person because I'm not
putting my time and effort to tear this
person down when they're already in a
shitty ass place I'm good that's good so
if I'm good I don't want to [__] on
somebody who's beneath me let them let
them do their [__] and guess what the
truth always reveals itself always and
it has always and within our group
within the whole everybody else they
started to see because it's first
started with oh you guys ejected this
person now you're a terrible person I'm
like cool I'll give you guys time you
you sit with that and then you come back
to me and apologize after and everybody
came back and apologized they go oh
because you know why every time they
hung out with that person guess what
they were doing talking [__] all the
time and then they would come to me what
do you think I don't care okay what do
you want to eat I don't care I just want
to know what's on the menu that's that's
me you know I'm content and happy where
I'm at and I don't have time for that I
don't have time for people in my life
that are going to tear down and that
I've had to you know it's again you've
got to do the necessary thing to protect
yourself and protect your loved ones and
your inner circles and and those tough
conversations need to happen but it's
it's a it's a loving thing to be honest
with somebody before they hurt
themselves before they hurt everyone
around them and end up ruling their
lives and then again sit in that
situation where everyone's left them and
then they still blame everyone else
instead of blaming themselves and seeing
Oh I'm the cause of the problem I'm the
one that's responsible here I think
again taking self-responsibility taking
ownership of your flaws and the good
things you have is a great way to just
be real and not too many of us want to
be real you know it's a sad truth but
the more real you are with yourself the
more honest and open and real you can be
with everyone else around you yeah and
being real too doesn't mean that you're
a [__] [__] like you can be honest
with the people around you with kindness
and love right and how you how you take
that on if people truly are in your when
they are your good friend you should be
able to listen to this right
that's the hard part sometimes we just
have people who are likable who want to
be your Echo chamber you just want to
hear somebody repeat back what you
already believe you know which when it
comes to good things that's great but
sometimes when you step out of place or
you step out of line you need somebody
to be like hey chill like my best
friend's out in New York right that full
he we always check each other all the
time that's good that's a good
relationship we agree with like 99 of
things but sometimes when we get out of
pocket we go hey man what the [__] you
doing man like I like that you know it's
accountability yeah and we've been with
each other through thick and thin we've
gone into heated arguments we've fought
about stupid [__] right I remember in
high school I was I pit this one's arms
to his chest and I socked his arms so
they went dead like we we've we've been
through some [__] together right but
because of that Honesty our friendship
is tighter than ever like that guy's my
brother you know and like I I feel sad
for people who sometimes don't expect
that out of the people around them
you know too many people aren't in
relationships like that that I feel like
that's a rarity now to see that a
long-lasting relationship where you're
honest and open with people I feel like
yeah I see so many relationships that
are it's all good I only talk about the
good things or you're hyping somebody
out there that doesn't build depth that
doesn't build truth you don't get to
actually know someone you don't actually
let yourself be known if you're not able
to be vulnerable and truthfully my lady
was going through a problem not I'm
sorry not a problem let's not say that
she was just kind of reassessing or
re-evaluing certain uh reevaluating
certain friendships with people that she
has that I've had a weird feeling about
right okay and you know me being her
husband I'm gonna speak my truth about
it I'll be like hey like I dislike it
when these people around you do this
this and that and then she also
expressed her feelings about this and
the the topic that I'm talking about
that's related to this is
she assumed that she had these friends
were really good friends right but
I said they're not really your friends
and she said this as well because you
tell them everything about your life but
they don't share anything about theirs
so you know so one-way street so
literally she had a conversation with
one of them they go okay also what are
you doing for work blah blah blah and
she tells her everything about her work
or whatever and they own a business they
go oh what's going on with your business
and this they go we can't tell you that
she's like what the [__] what you just
asked me about my personal life and my
work life I expressed that to you and
then me asking you about yours I'm out
of pocket like what
what do you how how I don't get it we're
friends right exactly are we friends
that's a one-way Street yeah make that
make sense to me yeah it don't make
sense at all and so you know I've
definitely when those friends come
around I'm a little rough with them yeah
you're a real one yeah that's what I
always tell you but you're a real one
and I respect you for that and I
appreciate that I would expect you to
check me if I'm if I come out of pocket
or I say some outlandish stuff you're
around like uh guys around comics who
say things out of pocket 24 7 it's gonna
be crazy the game true well a few of my
friends are comments but but not all of
them not all of them listen I've [__]
up so many times where like I'll go back
home to Sacramento and you know I'm over
here around comics we're joking around a
lot and I forget that my mentality is
this is the comics room and I go over to
regular people and the room is silent
and they're just mortified I'm like hey
my bad I forgot like I'm around almost
like a bro session yeah like I wasn't
prepared to have my heart thrown into a
bucket as you roasted me for fun I I get
that my buddy Jason Cheney this fool
just texted me the other day and he just
he always he always makes a [__] fat
joke I mean that has me crying laughing
like this guy legit he was just like
dude how are all three of your chins
doing and I'm like bro I just woke up
early for that 8 am in the morning why
the [__] am I waking up to this it's the
first thing you know first things
[__] like roast you in the
morning you want to go get dinner I know
you already had three of them did I just
get the fourth one and I'm like just
just just ask me if I want to eat bro
that is good I'm glad you know I I don't
think I got a thick skin like that
though I couldn't deal with things like
that we would be scrapping everybody put
these gloves leave me in the garage
right now that's good but I want to
knock you out I give you a ghost buddy
I'll give you some cool points for that
one I'll write that one down but we're
gonna fight but I'll tell you this
though I really do when I was out in
Hawaii and I I always see people like
Polynesians and Hawaiians like the way
they deal with their problems it's like
oh you talk that [__] you gotta you
gotta pay for it and it won't be cool
after which you don't see that a lot
like you see people scrap and then the
next like after they knock this guy out
they dab it up be like you good we good
all right respect let's get drinks and
then move the [__] on because you
there's consequences for this [__] there
is your actions might have some
consequences I'm so happy I'm learning
that my wife's uh Pacific Islander so uh
I I I'm well aware of the culture oh man
I've seen dudes just scrap it out I've
seen it multiple times man and I just
I'm like man in Hawaii I'm gonna have to
keep my [__] mouth shut like this is
someone's gonna beat my ass and
everybody's a UFC fighter here we're
gonna fight and then we're gonna have a
beer after uh just after you wake up
I'll tell you this after you knock me
out don't touch me
you stay over there I stay over here
we won't have to have those problems now
we've already sparred before so it'll be
cool we already know you and I will
never fight
Don't Say Never man come on don't say
never there's a there's a there's a
skill and a gap difference between
here I'm sorry but you know you know I
know how to work with Fighters man oh
yeah no you're actually very very nice
to Sparta Man and I think like people
who are really skilled at what they do
they know who they are so they don't
have anything to prove so I feel a lot
more safe and comfortable with it
because even for me because you know I'm
not trained like I'll have these moments
where I'm Spazzy and the person who's
more train should understand that like
oh he's new at this let's give him some
forgiveness always except if you're not
with that person who does that then it's
just going to be an all-out brawl and
you don't know what's going to happen
and I've experienced that a couple of
times and I did not like it I did not
like it at all and I felt terrible after
and I just because you already know the
story you know I did not like it I
didn't like the way I felt I didn't like
the way it felt during and it wasn't fun
anymore I've been there I've been there
before too brother and it all feel it
don't feel good when you work with
somebody that's trying to prove
something
um but I've had those seasons and that's
my past I don't need to prove nothing
them to anybody yeah and I am so
grateful for this season in my life
where I'm at now where again I can get
in a ring with people when I I don't got
to prove it to anybody I'm not trying to
show up there's no cameras on we're here
to enjoy the work have some fun and I
want to help you get better that's what
this is and that's the thing about being
a good coach too right which I I felt
like you know I switched around a lot of
coaches in my day just trying to sample
things out there's the one coach who
absolutely knows Jack all nothing and
they try to fake the funk with a lot of
beginner people which there was a [__]
ton of that a lot of that I had no
[__] idea I got a you know a few
dollars taken from me
but thank God I was switching around
other places I was like oh you're a liar
you actually don't know anything and I
looked them up I'm like oh where have
you trained certification have you even
boxed none of that get the [__] out of
my face there's a lot of people that can
fraudulently put themselves out there
and in the day and age that we're in
today again all it takes is a website a
few good pictures there's
and then you get somebody like me and
you know they didn't know what was
happening and then you have other
coaches who are not really malleable and
they train everybody the exact same way
even though everybody doesn't have the
same attributes and that was a tough one
for me too where um like I had a coach
who uh
didn't really like the way that I was
boxing because I was comfortable
I think I just like long hard you know
what I mean depending on the situation
right a lot of frames you know people
are different right if I have the reach
Advantage I'm going to use this but he
[__] hated that I was doing this but
I'm like listen if I'm 6'1 and you had
me sparring this guy that's five eight
why would I not use my reach you want to
stay right here in that job exactly I'm
gonna stay here if he's shelling up I'm
gonna use his shell you know what I mean
24 7 and he hated it he goes hands up
I'm like hands are up but he's [__]
his rage is shorter than my why would I
let him get close to me yeah and so I
got really really frustrated and he's
just like you know you're not gonna get
better I'm like
I just pieced up your boxer so and we're
at the same level but you're telling me
that I should have my hands up and get
close to him and get in that 50 50
position with him why oh hands up all
the time so are you hear that boxing
coaches all the time you got to have
your hands up all the time there's you
don't need to have your hands up all the
time there's a reason and a place for it
but yeah if you are not being a a cookie
cutter type of coach and you can be
malleable to help people and to be
specific and to give them specific
protocols you can help them a lot better
and then be more valuable to people I've
always learned that and that's one of
the things I'm still learning I'm still
growing I'm still a student in the game
I've been doing this for 20 years now so
I'm excited to continue to grow to
continue to learn and to continue to
help people in the day-to-day I love it
man and you know everybody uh you know
uh Shane Faison like I think yeah fight
tips maybe five tips man and that's like
it's so crazy that whole that whole
world because that's where I saw you but
then I met you through Bart and I
actually met Shane through Bart as well
small world small world man and I I used
to watch the videos all the time right I
couldn't do any of the stuff but I used
to watch it all the time and then you
know Shane said something great it's
like you learn the rules to break them
right learn the foundation first and
then figure out what works well for you
afterwards Shane's a master brother I
missed that guy we used to put a lot of
work in and I I'll always credit Shane
uh for a lot of growth for me being a
content creator and a coach and how to
actually I thought I was a student and
then me and Shane are hanging out one of
the first times we're kicking it
watching UFC fight and my man had the
notepad out and the pen during the
prelims and is taking notes and watching
everything like Shane you are you're a
psychopath and I love this bro let's go
yeah yeah the fight tips years were
great I haven't done a fight tips video
in like five years I feel like he's all
over the place Shane Shane's uh Shane's
home on the East Coast making himself
happy and enjoying life and still
putting out great content I see him he
still does fighting teams man come on
you gotta check the fight tips out man
but if I tips was a segue to get me
learning and to continually be creating
and now being part of fight camp where I
get to train teach and coach people all
around the world every day yeah because
I was watching his videos the other day
and I was like wait this is not the same
because he was doing he was traveling in
his van for a bit so I didn't know where
his home base is anymore I'm like it's
not California for sure so I'm like
where the [__] did he go I mean I left
left the best coast I don't know I don't
know if he already made that
announcement or anything but uh yeah the
homie the homies no longer hanging out
with me on a weekly basis but he's still
doing great you know him and the family
and Sally they're crushing it I'm really
proud of him I gotta get out there and
visit soon I think we're gonna we're
gonna make an East Coast trip in like
May or something so he's like one of
those guys that's like
he really lives up to the name of being
a true martial artist Shane's a real one
I mean like I said I say you're a real
one but but also Shane is in that
category as well for people that I know
like and trust and have been around them
enough and seen their expertise their
care to the minute details and he's a
he's a master Craftsman when I first met
him I said one thing to him I was like
amen so you know when you train it's
like how do you stay fit all the way all
year round he's like well if I'm a
martial artist and my body's my temple
I'm going to take care of it I was like
well thank you I feel like a piece of
[__] now
[Music]
is great oh it's fine when people say in
and out is not good you'd [__]
tripping dude trash these people's
opinions which are entitled to them
that's trash I'm sorry I'm entitled to
my opinion about your opinion right yeah
we should go I'll say this like you
could say that it's not your favorite
burger it's a good burger
it's not my favorite there's a lot of
burger spots in L.A though I hit up
anyway uh we could be on a three-hour
podcast we're talking about burgers dog
well guys uh [__] that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast PJ
where can they find you oh man you guys
can find me at trainwithpj on all social
media platforms also you can train with
me with fight Camp so join fightcamp.com
and if you want to listen to my podcast
check out the bde podcast on Spotify
let's go uh genius